Speaker 2: Donald Trump held a rally in Ohio on
Saturday night. It was ostensibly for J.D. Vance,
who's the Republican Senate candidate there
running against Tim Ryan. This was the most
cultish Trump rally I have ever seen.
A new staple at the Trump rallies is
that when Donald Trump is doing his kind of
final build to his Make America Great Again,
Make America safe again. They now play, I don't
even know, like like an esoteric musical bed that
almost seems fake. It almost seems like a parody.
This is the one of the strangest moments I've
ever seen at any political rally, ever. Globally,
experts on fascism and cults are poring over this
video like the Zapruder film. Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: We are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country, Ukraine killing hundreds of
thousands of people. And it will only get worse.
Speaker 2: And what you can see there is the cult
people holding up a single finger. Now there's to
it. There's a bunch of interpretations of this.
One is there's this Cunanan thing, which is like,
I forget. Exactly. It's like w wg one WGA. And
what the phrase means is where one of us goes,
we will go together. And so the one that is being
held could be the one from that Cunanan thing.
Another interpretation is they're doing the Heil
Hitler, but with a single finger to make it less
crazy looking. I don't think that that's what this
is. It's insane. But this is a very serious cult.
Speaker 5: It would never have happened
with me as your commander in chief. And
for four long years it didn't happen. And China
with Taiwan is next. We are a nation that has
weaponized its law enforcement against the
opposing political party like never, ever before.
We've got a Federal Bureau of Investigation
that won't allow bad election changing
facts to be presented to the public.
We're Hunter Biden's laptop, folks.
Speaker 2: This is the United States.
This is a former president up.
Speaker 5: With Russian disinformation when
they knew it wasn't. And a Department of
Justice that refuses to investigate egregious
acts of voting irregularities and fraud.
And we have a president who is cognitively
impaired and in no condition to lead our country,
which may end up in World War Three.
Speaker 2: Yet somehow, I don't think so.
Speaker 5: We are a nation that no longer
has a free press and has no fair press any
longer. Fake news is all you get, and they are
truly the enemy of the people. We are a nation
where free speech is no longer allowed,
where crime is rampant like never before,
where the economy has been collapsing, where
more people died of COVID in 2021 than in 2020.
We are a nation that is allowing Iran to build
a massive nuclear weapon and China to use the
trillions of dollars it has taken from us.
Speaker 2: All right. Let's pause it here
like nothing I have ever seen before. Truly
and completely fascistic. These are sort of
like dictatorial, wet dreams. I mean, this this
would make Fidel Castro blush, quite frankly,
later on. A lot of other of the typical things
also happen during this speech. Later on,
Donald Trump seemed to forget where he was
like where he was giving the speech. And he
referred to it as this location in McKinley.
Speaker 5: You know, he's a great president.
He was the king of tariffs. That's why I like him,
because he said that we don't want other foreign
powers coming in here and stealing our wealth.
He was hailed from right here. He came in from
this right, this location.
Speaker 3:
That's the best.
Speaker 2: He was such
an important place he was from. It was
from right this pier where we are now.
Donald Trump still completely scrambled on Ulysses
s Grant, continuing to. First of all, it's weird
how much Trump refers to Ulysses S Grant, and it's
also weird that he keeps calling them Ulysses.
Speaker 5: For their beloved country.
Ohio is the state that gave us
American heroes, icons and legends with names
like Neil Armstrong, Annie Oakley, and the
great general and President Ulysses S Grant.
Speaker 2: He was there as Ulysses. Still,
you would think someone would come up to
him with tears in their eyes and say, Sir,
it's Ulysses. Of Donald Trump bemoaned the claims
about a urine tape involving Trump, saying it was
really tough to explain that one to Melania.
Speaker 5: In the phony Steele dossier,
it was all phony. How would you like to be me
and go home and explain that one to my wife?
Darling, it wasn't true, I swear, was it? I
remember that one with the hookers from Russia.
Darling, I'd like to explain this to you. It
was all phony. It was all a phony made up.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it was all fake. And then
lastly, it wasn't all fun and games. There
was a moment where the crowd in Ohio was so
bored that they were in complete silence.
And at one point in this clip, if you're
watching, you'll see the camera cut to
the crowd there. They almost look like statues.
Speaker 5: And 100% would have never happened.
Should've never happened. But we gave.
Speaker 3: Now.
Speaker 5: $80 billion and Europe has given
six. Now, Europe is a similar size when all
added up to the United States, the economy
of Europe, if you add it all up and they're
in for a lot less money than us. And, you know,
it's a sad thing because they're in for less,
but they're affected a lot more than we are.
Speaker 2: Yeah, just an electric environment
there. An electric atmosphere. So a deranged rally
in Ohio was supposedly in support of J.D. Vance at
one point during the thing Trump actually
made fun of. JD Vance It's all backwards.
It was all completely. People's brains are
turning to mayonnaise at these rallies, is
what it seems like. And of course, the attendees
weren't much better. Let's look at that. Next,